what can you tell us well yeah this is
an update on the government's plans to
house uh migrants that arrive primarily
by small boats into the south of England
now my colleague Ali portugu has learned
from a government source that plans to
use a giant cruise ship to house Asylum
seekers in birkenhead or merseyside in
the Northwest have been scrapped by the
government after the plan was rejected
by peel ports essentially the owner of
the area the owner of the port where the
barge would have been now it was due to
hold 500 Asylum Seekers and was one of
seven sites announced by the government
to start taking migrants I think this
just shows the difficulty in
implementing the practicalities of the
government plan to try and swiftly
detain people that arrive by methods
they deem illegal house them and then
try and Deport them as quickly as
possible because you need a vast
quantity of space of rooms of
accommodation to try and House people
and those plans frequently run into
local objections and that is what
appears to have happened here plans
being scrapped for a giant cruise ship
in birkenhead after the port owner
appeal ports declined the plan